voilà Monsieur bonsoir On est tous un
peu orphelin ce soir George Harrison a
accompagné plusieurs générations il
était le plus discret le plus jeune des
Beatles sa disparition laisse le cœur
gros à toute l'Angleterre qui se
retrouve dans les paroles de Paul
mccartne qui le considérit comme son
petit frère l'hommage d'un payé en deuil
à l'OND Bernard
lebrin drapeau en berne au cityall
Liverpool et les Beatles la ville
portuaire et la bande des quat ne font
qu'un depuis 40 ans alors qu'en George
sétin la mairie prend le deuil un
registre de condoléance a été ouvert dès
ce matin la ville était au travail et
seul quelques jeunes qui n'ont connu des
bitles que la légende sont venus dire
leur émotion et puis il y a ceux et
celles qui ont grandi avec
eux ma première réaction a été une
grande tristesse j'ai un lien très fort
avec les Beatles je viens de Liverpool
j'ai grandi avec
eux et leur musique aussi a beaucoup
influencé mes
enfants dans cette ville musée dédié au
Beatles le premier cabaret où ils ont
joué en 1961 accueiller cet après-midi
les fans de tous âges émus sur fond de
something grand tube écrit par char
harison Paul marartne qui l' appelit son
petit frère est apparu très touché par
la disparition de son copain de
lycée c'était un type fantastique avec
beaucoup d'humour j'ai eu la chance de
le voir il y a 15 jours et il était de
bonne humeur amusant comme à son
habitude c'est un homme courageux et un
très grand privilège de l'avoir
ils ne traverseront plus jamais ensemble
le passage clouté de la route de l'abay
où se trouve encore le studio mythique
des Beatles à Londres aujourd'hui le mur
de la studio s couvert de mot d'amour le
Premier ministre lui s'est contenté d'en
faire
part nous avons tous grandi avec les
Beatles leur musique leur personnalité
nous ont accompagné toute notre vie les
G son trèsristés
par d'humour et il restera dans
l'histoire de la presse britannique en
raison de ses réponses fameuses l'une de
celles-ci était les Beatles ne se
reconstitueront jamais tant que John
Lennon est
mort